على تاكيد التزام المملكه
لتنظيم اكسبو يخدم العالم السيد الرئيس
اصحاب المعالي
الضيوف الكرام
ان الرياض جاهزه
واكسبو الرياض سوف يبنيه العالم من اجل
العالم
ان العمل قد بدا بالفعل
ونحن نخطط لبناء
اكسبو 2020 والانتهاء من العمل قبل الاجل
ان اختيار
[موسيقى]
سوف يجعلنا نبدا العمل فورا
اتفاقيهنا تم
الموافقه عليها من قبل
الحكومات ونحن مستعدون
البدء عمليه التسجيل بطريقه سريعه ان
الاراضي التي تصدى ضيف اكسبو 2020 جاهزه
واستطيع ان اضمن انه بحلول فبراير من عام
فان الاجزاء التي المشاركه في اكسبو ستكون
جاهزه وقريه اكسبو ستكون جاهزه
وكمدينه
[موسيقى]
لدينا تجربه طويله في بناء مشاريع من
الطراز العالمي
بالاشتراك مع الشركات العالميه على سبيل
المثال
[موسيقى]
اين
في طريقها لتكون من افضل عشر اقتصادات
حضاريه في العالم ومركز عالمي
للانشطه المصرفيه والتجاريه والرياضيه
والترفيه ان نمونا
يولد
فرص هائله للعالم
وهذا ما سيفعله اكسبو 2020
ان موقع اكسبو بحد ذاته
يقع في موقع الاستراتيجي بضع دقائق فقط عن
مطار الملك سلمان الجديد الذي
تضيف اكثر من 120 مليون زائر في عام 2030
ريال
في الرياض سوف ترون
مشاهد طبيعيه من الطراز العالمي مثل
حديقه الملك سلمان التي سوف تصبح قريبا
اوسع حديقه حضاريه في العالم
والمربع
الذي يجمع
اشكال هندسيه مذهله ودكتوراه القديم
والواقع الافتراضي
والدرعيه
هذا الموقع
التاريخي وموقع الفئه التراث العالمي
اليونسكو والجديه مستقبل الترفيه والرياضه
والفنون
[موسيقى]
في عالم صاحب السمو الملكي الولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان
نحن واثقون
بقدرتنا لانجاز
عالمي غير مسبوق
حتى
احدثكم عن الخطه الرئيسيه
الرياض دعوني اعطي الكلمه الى زميلتي
لمياء ونوف شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صاحب المعالي شكرا للضيوف الكرام اود ان
احدثكم اليوم عن خطتنا الرئيسيه التي سوف
تسمح بتنظيم اكسبو غير مسبوق اولا سنوفر
تجربه غير لا منافسه لاكثر من اربعين
مليون وسوف نسمح ايضا ثانيا المشاركه ذات
المغزى لكافه الدول ثالثا سوف نجعل
المستدامه المستقبل المحدد
لموقعنا المبني والمستقبل دعونا نبدا
بتجربه الزوار قبل الانطلاق سيتمكن الزوار
من الاستفاده من خدمات وكذلك عروض النقل
حتى يمكن ان يخططوا رحله لدى الوصول الى
مطار الملك سلمان سوف يمر الزوار عبر
الجمارك
بتاشيره خاصه
[موسيقى]
يمكن للدول ان تطور عروض
للاجنحه ضمن
الحديقه اكسبو
سوف نساعد مئه بلدان مؤهله
للحصول على حياه ثانيه لجناحتها من خلال
المدارس والعيادات والمراكز في بلدانها
وعلاوه على الاجنحه فان اماكن ثقافيه تسمح
لبلدان بتنظيم ايام وطنيه وعروض واحتفالات
ونحن ملتزمون للاهتمام بمن يساعدنا في
بناء
ستتضمن فرص
[موسيقى]
المتنوعه ونعمل لاطلاق مختبر
اوساكا سوف يقدم خدمات على مدى ساعات
اليوم الاربعاء والعشرين ويمثل تحدي وصولا
الى وبعد
بالنسبه
للمباني مباني الموقع اعطي الكلمه الان
الى زميلتي
[تصفيق]
شكرا لك لمياء ايها الضيوف الكرام فيما
يتعلق بالاستدامه نريد ان نكون اول اكسبو
خالي من الكربون على الاطلاق موقع اكسبوس
سوف يحصل على طاقته من الطاقه النظيفه
بفضل الطاقه الشمسيه المتوفره في المملكه
تطور معايير
واستراتيجيات لتشجيئه تنوع البيولوجي
والقضاء على حظر الغذاء ضمان الاداره
المستدامه للطاقه نتبنى ايضا افضل معايير
الدوليه لتنقل والوصول وحقوق العمال بما
في ذلك المتعاقدين من الباطن
بالنسبه لي او سنقدم ايضا
شركات متعدده الاطراف تعزز اهداف التنميه
المستدامه
وموضوع اكسبو والموضوعات الفرعيه
يكون لدى
ويحتضن المشاريع الدوليه بحلول عام 2025
ويتم عرضها في اكسبو ان مبادئ العداله
وشموليه والاستدامه ستكون ايضا ضمن
علاماتنا المميزه
وهذا سيكون منقسم على كافه البشريه حيث
يكون هناك حوالي 230 متر مربع مخصصه لهذا
المشروع سيمثل ذلك علما وكذلك نظام
المتنوع سيكون هناك 195
ركيزه تسلط الضوء على جوده الدول
ومسؤوليتنا المشتركه لدعم كوكبنا وكافه من
يعيشون عليها ان ذلك سوف يسلط الدور على
اكسبو كمركز للرؤيه المستقبليه والالتزام
لبناء المستقبل الذي نستحقه معا دون
الايطالي دعوني اعرض عليكم لمحه عن ما
سيدكون عليه اكسبو 2020 ثم سيتحدث خالد
الفالح وزير الاستثمار
كل الخطه الرئيسيه والحديث عن الفرص التي
يقدمها اكسبو للعالم
[موسيقى]
السيد الرئيس
اصحاب السمو والمعالي
الضيوف الكرام كما سمعتم
التجارب التي سيقدمها
الرياض ستكون مذهله ولكن دعوني اؤكد ان
هذا يحدث ضمن
وتمازيا مع بيئه الاستثمار والمشاريع التي
هي لا حدود لها كوزيل للاستثمار هي مهمتي
نضمن ان
الفوائد لنمونا الهائل يتم تقاسمها بشكل
واسع ليس في المملكه فقط ولكن في المنطقه
وايضا في العالم برمباتها وحتى اعطيكم
ارقام تحت قياده صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان وكان جزء من الرؤيه عشرين
ثلاثين نستهدف استثمارات لاكثر من 3 ثلاثه
تريليون دولار امريكي في المملكه
بنهايه هذا العقد ومنها اكثر من ثلاثين
بالمئه
ستكون في مدينه الرياض بمفردها
وميزانيه اكسبو 2020 التي تبلغ 7.8 مليار
دولار هي تحفز مشاريع الاستثمار في الرياض
واود ان اتحدث اليوم عن ثلاثه موضوعات اول
كيف ان بنا عشرين ثلاثين سيفيد العالم من
خلال تقاسم فرص الاعمال ثانيا انشاء مختبر
اقتصادي عالمي واخيرا وليس اخيرا من خلال
تاثيرها على الاستدامه
منذ انشائي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الحديثه التي بدات في مدينه الرياض فان
تنميتنا الوطنيه ساهمت كثيرا في نمو ورفاه
دول اخرى ومواطنيها
واليوم في المملكه لدينا ما يربو على 25
الف
شركه عالميه من بينها
4500 مسجله في مجال الهندسه والبناءات
وهذه الشركات الخمسه وعشرين الف وتوظف
اكثر ثمانيه
الافليون موظف من اكثر 130 بلدا واضمن لكم
مؤكد لكم ان المزيد من العماله سوف
والشركات سوف تاتي للمشاركه في اكسبو
سنخلق من خلال اكسبو
مركز مشتريات واحد لتيسير الاعمال
والمساهمه في تصميم المشاريع وتنفيذها في
اكسبو
اطلاقها
وهذا سيسمح لرؤيتنا من اجل اكسبو يبنيه
العالم ومن اجل العالم ثانيا نريد ان
نستفيد اقصى حد من فرص اكسبو 2020
والمتعاقدين موقع اكسبو سيكون مركز اجتماع
لميلي كافه الشركات العالميه
للبحث عن فرص في المملكه ومن ذلك سنطلق
مختبر الاستثمار عالمي سيكون مركز ابتكار
لكافه الدول ونقطه التقاء وممكن للشركات
ورواد الاعمال
يجعل البلدان المشاركه للاكتشاف والابتكار
والتعاون معا سوف نساوي
ونشجع المستثمرين من خلال الاستثمار في
المدن الذكيه والتكنولوجيا والاصول
الخضراء وغيرها
ثالثا
لن يتزامن فقط مع انجاز رؤيه المملكه
الشجاعه ولكنها التاريخ ايضا من اجل اهداف
التنميه المستدامه في الرياض كما سمعتم هي
في صلب الكثير من المبادرات الاستدامه
للمدينه وللمملكه وكذلك للمنطقه ككل سوف
نقدم تجاربنا المتنوعه ومواردنا وشبكتنا
لمختبر الاستثمار العالمي والاكسبو سي
ثلاثه
لتسجيل الاستثمار وجلبه الاستثمار الاخضر
وتقاسم الفوائد في العالم
وبالتالي لكل الدول الشباب الماليين
بالامل في جميع ربوع العالم للحالمين
المفكرين المبتكرين والرواد الاعمال
ستجدون
الرياض
سيوفر لكم فرصا تكون جزءا لا يتجزا من هذه
الرحله
المليئه بتحولات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مع الرياض في صلبها وليقول لكم
المزيد عن هذه الرحله سوف تشاهدون بعض ذلك
فيديو عن اكبر رواد الاعمال يعبرون عن
التزامهم تجاه اكسبو 2020
وبعد ذلك ستسمعون من
سعاده السفير قديمه بنت بندر ال سعود
سعاده السفيره شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
مسيره
غير مسبوقه تسمح للقطاع العام والخاص
والقطاع الثالث التعاون من اجل انجاز رؤيه
شجاع نريد ان نقدم للعالم بالطاقه التي
يحتاجها وشركه اراكم تعمل من اجل تحقيق
طموحنا بصفي انبعاثات الكربون بحول لعام
2030 هذه منصه تسمح لنا باستغلال قدراتنا
وهذه موطن لنظام
يقوده الشباب المتعلمون من رواد الاعمال
وذلك من اجل بناء عالم اكثر استدامه
وازدهار نحن متحمس
جزءا من مختبر الرياض سي ثلاثه ودفع
الابتكارات في مجال المنا خ سيكون هناك
فرص للتعاون
الانشاء او خلق
معاكسر استدامه للعلم فتطلع
لاستضافتكم في الرياض شركه ارامكو فخوره
ان تدعم
اكسبو الرياض 20 30 اهلا وسهلا بكم في
الرياض نتطلع لاستقبالكم في الرياض
الملكي اصحاب المعالي والسعاده يسعدني ان
نقدم لكم
عرض المملكه العربيه السعوديه لاستضافه
اكسبو 2020
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تنتظر ان
يكتشف العالم هذه الوجهه المليئه بالحياه
التي تقدم تراثا ثقافين غني وكذلك تطورات
حديثه شعبنا
مضياف وكرامتنا
ولد في شبه الجزيره العربيه هذا جزء من
تراث ونتطلع الاستضافتكم نحن ملتزمون
لتوفير اعظم اكسبو للعالم يبنيه العالم
ومن اجل العالم ومنذ سنوات لهذه الدوله
شراكه كانت اساسيه لنجاحاتنا وستكون كذلك
بالنسبه لكم انجزنا مشاريع عملاقه
والمدن المستقبليه والحدائق والغابات
الحضري تلاحظون هذه المشاريع لم تنجز من
قبلنا ولكن بالاشتراك مع شركات عالميه هذه
الطريقه في العمل هذا الساده والسيدات
ننجزه وسوف ننجز ذلك من اجلكم قبل الاجيال
المحدده والاهم من ذلك نحن شغفون في مجال
السياحه وملتزمون بالممارسات السياحيه
المستدامه
وهذا لا يفيد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فقط ان السياحه يمكن ان تكون قوه للخير في
العالم
وان
السفر يربط الشعوب ويبني الجسور ويجلب
القارات
الرياض لديها قصص استثنائيه
ان قصه المملكه العربيه السعوديه وقصه
الريات قصتنا تتكشف امام عيونكم دون اي
فصول تكتب كل يوم كان هناك الكثير من
التغيرات التي حصلت في المملكه في السنوات
الثمانيه الماضي اكثر مما حصل في الثمانين
عاما الماضيه تصوروا ما ستكون عليه
المملكه بحلول عام 2030 في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه سيكون هناك كثير من
الامور اذا رغبتم تكون من المستكشفون يمكن
ان تقوموا بذلك الاستكشاف مواقع اليونسكو
لتراث العالمي اذا رغبت في ان تكونوا
مغامرين يمكن ان يتاح لكم ذلك ايضا
او تريدون ان تشاركوا في افضل المهرجانات
الموسيقيه في المنطقه او تتواجد في اعلى
سواحل المملكه الملايين اليوم يكتشفون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه للمره الاولى
وفي عام 2030 نتوقع
استقبال اكثر من 100 مليون زائر اكثر
اربعين منهم سيزورون اكسبو وصلنا نجرب
تجاربكم وثقافتكم وكل زائر سيرحب به
الاستفاده من التكنولوجيات وسيكون هناك
ايضا زوار افترا ديون سيكون هذا
مستند على فيزا خاصه لاكسبو واكثر من ذلك
سوف تتعرفون اصولنا الاساسيه الا وهي شعوب
شعبنا وشبابنا نحن امه مقارنه بامم كثيره
63% من سكانهم مادون من سن 30 وهم من
المترابطين مع العالم هم مستقبلنا
وكمستهلك ومسافرين هم ايضا مستقبلكم
ونتطلع لربطكم معهم
سيركز على التواصل والتنوع والشموليه
والكل مرحب به بغض النظر عن بلدانكم
وثقافتكم واعراقكم واجناسكم او ديانتكم
الرياض جاهزه لاستقبالكم وستكتشفون قريبا
ان السعوديه هي ارض بسحريه تنتظر من
يكتشفها اكسبو 20 30 في الرياض ندعوكم
لتجربه حقبه التغيير معا شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات